are you doing I'm feeling very nice
tonight I'm good the boys in the band
came through for spell yeah they're good
there's good camaraderie going on I feel
like I'm kind of part of the band cuz I
followed y'all all over creation and now
we're yeah you have been all over every
every city we went to I have seen you
there you've been so supportive of the
film some people call it working some
people call it stalking I hope you call
it working no I feel like it's working
it's not stalking at this point I love
what you're wearing
thank you I'm channeling mr. mercury
giving you a little judge tonight I'm
giving it to you again some extra love
tonight thank you you have how about
that it's it's been it's been
breathtaking I mean to get a Golden
Globe was one thing you just you dream
about these moments as an actor as a
young man and when they come to fruition
you almost just can't believe that it's
happening so no really and then to get
an Oscar nomination the other day was
it's obviously the highlight of my
career that's something I will have for
the rest of my life and as a young man
to ever think that that moment was
possible I just I thought it was out of
reach and it just proves that we can
achieve our dreams if we put put the
work in it can happen the guys told me
after the Golden Globes there was a
little bit of a late night ending up
about 4:00 in the morning at your
apartment they talk those boys talk so
much yeah why wouldn't you I mean that's
what you have to do on on occasions like
that how do you top 4:00 a.m.
cross-legged on your apartment floor
what the thing about the thing about
hanging out with those boys is it's an
the whole cast it's a relationship like
I've never had on a set before I mean
the gang on mr. robot is incredibly
tight I did it something called the
Pacific where we did boot camp together
so that was that was as tight as well
but there's something here where we
communicate every day and to celebrate
tonight with this ensemble that I could
have not done
without no way no how is a really
momentous occasion so win or lose this
group knows how to party this will be a
good table to be at tonight for
everybody at home
Mohini Arab City table will be crunk I'm
gonna pace myself but we'll see about
them by the way everybody's going crazy
over your twin brother oh yeah that's
what's been happening ever since I was a
kid so for me to get into acting and get
some limelight back he's a teacher he's
extraordinary I get to go to his school
every once in a while yeah
my older sister who's a doctor I brought
my sister here my mom here today the
family's here the last time I talked to
your mom was in London and she couldn't
stop gushing over you I can't wait to
see mama if you win tonight Mama's gonna
lose her most she's good I mean she's
got we got the globe under our belt
everything else is extra it's just it's
a joy to be able to share these moments
with your family question do you
remember the role that got you your sag
card your this is a great story do we
have time for this story i I was
submitting myself and he's worried we
don't have time are we live I hope we're
not live then that's ed back there you
know where are we at how's that
I was submitting myself I was submitting
myself for roles stuffing manila manila
envelopes with my headshot and resume to
anyone who would listen and I got a call
one day from a casting director she said
can I speak with Romney Malik's agent
and I said speaking and she said all
right well can you give me some
information as he has sagged part of
this Screen Actors Guild losing my head
here and I said no not yeah and she goes
well okay we need to talk further about
this and I said listen this is rami
malek and i am representing myself and
she laughed a little bit and I said we
can work on getting me a sag card as
well it's a few lines in the show that
Gilmore Girls and you're kind of
laughing right now so I'm gonna hop on
the bus and be there in about ten
minutes if that's cool with you
and maybe we can see how this goes and
she actually says Mara Casey and she
said you know what come on in kid and
that day the next day I got my sag card
Mallik are you kidding me
true story your story is the stuff
dreams are made of sorry that's why
that's what makes these moments so
celebratory for me I love her and every
other casting director that helped me to
get here
[Music]